imagine driving a car at 500 miles an
hour then double it this is what that
might look and sound like faster than
the speed of sound it's a dream that a
team of British engineers have spent 10
million pounds hoping to achieve the
Bloodhound supersonic racing car is
slowly taking shape its cockpit the only
part that's totally complete has been
made to measure for the pilot wing
commander Andy green it's gonna be a
fairly extreme set of physical
sensations got a huge amount of power in
this car 135,000 thrust horsepower it's
going to be accelerating at over 2g 40
miles an hour per second
the energy that's going on over the
cockpit and the noise that comes through
to me is going to be quite chattering so
I've got a lot of sound protection built
into the cockpit built into my earphones
it will still be very noisy the team of
60 people has spent the last seven years
working on the project using technology
that's a mix of Formula One and
aerospace the rear of the Bloodhound
will house not one but three engines
including a v8 a jet and a rocket all
that will combine to reach land speeds
hopefully faster than ever before it's
not just about breaking records almost
all the aspects of the design and the
build are available online something
that's unusual for an engineering
project on this scale well normally if
you're in f1 you don't want to give away
your competitive advantage you don't
want to share the drawings or the
potential colors that you're going to be
releasing with us we are designing a one
in a million car it's M we've been only
ones with a typhoon jet engine you can't
really steal it sorry the drawings that
we've got so we can we're able to share
everything that we're doing the first
attempt to break the thousand mile an
hour barrier will be made in the south
desert next year but all those many
hours of work will rely on finding one
thing the perfect run Harriet Hadfield
Sky News Bristol